finance bros and stock pickers on tv and
youtube love to tell you guys where to
put your money but the dirty secret of
this industry is that they are very
often raw
so today i want to show you guys what
happens when overconfidence gets met
with reality so i grabbed a financial
analyst found the worst finance
predictions that aged like milk
immediately after and today we're just
gonna play a referee and have fun with
this and rate them how bad of a call
were they really let's begin
ladies and gentlemen welcome to another
episode of the coffeezilla christmas i'm
your host coffeezilla in the 10 million
dollar studio today we have a very
special guest richard coffin of the
plain bagel he's an investment analyst
say hi hello guys how's it going coffee
thank you for having me on absolutely
let's begin
very strong earnings these stocks are
they do i don't even know them what do
they do
uh excuse me what is upstart too uh well
i'm i'm
i'm sorry what kind of company is it
yeah i'm not you're you're breaking up
oh uh well i guess we've got an audio
problem there i don't think it's an
audio problem
that's uh that's a bad call i think we
can agree that i wanted to start with
the baseline that's a bad call that's
pretty close to it as pretty close to a
10 as you can get i think yeah we're
doing a one to ten scale one is bad luck
it could have happened to anybody a 10
is a bad call that's just a bad call
that hurts me to watch that
it's i feel genuine pain yeah it's your
job as an investment analyst to
know what these stocks are that's why
you go on shows like this this guy
ostensibly is some kind of a expert
right my guess would be he's like a
technical analyst to some degree like
more short term and there are technical
analysts who like don't really care what
the company does they just look at the
charts and stuff but i mean i think
you'd like google the company before
you know
yeah exactly that's it makes me lose a
bit of faith in financial journalism all
right dude we're calling that a bad call
i think that's a 10 that's a 10 for me
uh
bad up next we're going to look at some
of the historical bad takes that aged
like milk starting with
the dot-com bubble the investment bank's
stock analysts went on television and
touted stock after stock after stock at
the heart of it was the mad scramble by
bankers and venture capitalists to take
hundreds of unprofitable young internet
companies public say the internet is so
revolutionary that the usual rules for
valuing a stock such as revenues and
earnings no longer apply
[Applause]
profits don't matter anymore it's uh
sometimes sales don't even matter which
is which is encouraging
you know what i've heard recently
actually i've heard the same argument
being like propped up again by crypto by
certain i just talked to a guy finance
guy he's like yeah i think meme coins
like they don't need to do anything
they're valuable because of the meme i
was like that's exactly like what these
guys are saying hey if you if you're
hype enough you don't need profits you
don't need to do anything that's going
to be the next iteration of the cfa
curriculum when you become a financial
analyst chartered financial analyst it's
going to be you know measuring the
memeology of uh
stocks and
discounted mean flows
yeah yeah that's kind of mean plus i
love that yeah uh okay well i'm gonna go
ahead and say another pretty that's a
bad call pretty bad yeah some people can
argue when it comes to starting off not
making money is okay as long as they're
gonna keep growing but you know if sales
don't matter profits don't matter then
nothing matters
nothing
the memes matter i guess all right let's
see the next one what do we have up here
so this is richard quest i believe he
was a bnn business journalist at the
time and he's talking about the
the dot-com companies at the time by the
way this is documentary from 1999 so
like the year before the the bubble
burst um so it's it's it's a
chef's kiss uh type of clip
i'm not normally described of as
described as perverse but you've got to
be perverse to say the market's going to
crash it may have a major correction but
with low inflation low unemployment low
interest rates strong corporate earnings
i would be a certifiable lunatic if i
said the market was going to crash
[Music]
wow
[Music]
why the slo-mo
[Music]
god bless so bad this is not a fad this
is a revolution that's affecting the way
we do business and live our lives and
that's why it's so profitable wow so
this was a year before the the burst
1999 yeah yeah right before the crash
glove.com was like one of the most
famous
dot com bursts like it was i think it's
a record for the biggest ipo basically
like a social media company at the time
you know he's right about the internet
like obviously he's right it's not a fad
it ended up changing our lives right
you'd have to be insane to say there's
going to be a crash coming literally the
year before it happens
yeah i i i'm kind of more of a five with
this one right i'm more in the middle i
would i would give it maybe a
like a a six or a seven just because you
have to be a certifiable lunatic i'd
have to be a certified that's true it's
a little aggressive yeah it's so
aggressive but you're absolutely you're
right there is there's a certain luck
element to where he could have said that
in a year but doing it right before the
crash that's incredible he said
something about earnings like the
dot-com bubble famously like earnings
weren't there like and you know it kind
of touched on it earlier like analysts
were saying no profits don't matter
right now so that was kind of misguided
like saying you know that's why there's
so much money being made well there
wasn't actually that much like maybe for
investors at the time and investment
banks especially but
you know not really for the
com companies themselves so wow okay
well i think i think we're roughly on
the same page there our next clip we got
here is from 2006
right before the big crash a warning was
given let's see if they listen 45
unemployment rate uh gdp is growing the
demographics in other words family
formations all the things that factor
into housing
playing in here and as that is why we
might not have to crash
most of the profits that people have in
real estate are going to vanish just
like the profits in the in the dot coms
in 1999 2000. it's a fantasy people
can't sell their house the inventories
are exploding all over that guy's so
smug it's pissing me off it's making
that's so fast that's the face everyone
imagines when they think of the finance
industry i think
oh
laughing no you think this is gonna ever
end no we're gonna the party's gonna
keep going houses are on the market for
six months a year there's no bidders so
the prices are gonna fall through the
floor you guys were diluting yourself
we heard it loud and clear we have two
people here right we have peter schiff
who's actually making the accurate
statement uh but peter schiff is kind of
like known as being a perma bear like
he's negative nine out of ten days yeah
um and he's always peddling things like
gold and stuff so you know take out the
grain of salt but you know with 2008
warning signs in 2006 and talking about
essentially what played out and then we
have uh mike norman i think his name is
and just hard to watch
this guy right here right the guy who's
like what
what so what yeah i'm gonna go ahead and
say this is a tin
bad call on his part because here he is
literally someone's reading him his
rights as far as like hey this is
exactly what's going to happen and he's
like what it's going to be fine yeah
it's it's over confidence at it
it's sort of like yeah home prices are
up therefore they will always be up like
that's rarely ever held in in economic
history but again one of those things
really age like milk
give it a score here uh so i'm gonna
give it an eight there were warning
signs but also you know times were good
and
money was being made but also
that laugh i'll bump it up to a nine
just from that laughing all right
next meme
not a meme next clip it's
without being flippant to even
see a scenario within any kind of realm
of reason that would see us losing one
dollar in any of those transactions
wait what am i watching here and who is
cassano this guy's face is unbelievable
so this is joseph cassano he was an
executive at aig which was one of the
companies that really proliferated the
issues of the dot
com the 2008 financial crisis not to get
too technical but they sold credit
default swaps which were one of the
things behind the financial crisis and
that's what he's talking about he's
saying you know without being flipping
it's hard to say hard to imagine that we
lose any money on these financial
products they were essentially insurance
contracts on things like mortgages so
when mortgages started defaulting
imagine an insurance you know provider
having to pay out millions of millions
all at once for all these institutions
that's effectively what we're seeing in
2007. it's called the 2008 financial
crisis the warning signs were coming up
in 2007 uh that's when things started to
default that's when people started to
realize oh there's an issue here kind of
late in the game to say that you don't
expect to lose any money yeah i'm
finding a lot of these i'm just finding
these to be bad but maybe it's all
because of hindsight i'm gonna give this
a seven i'm gonna give it a nine
next clip oh this is gonna be good oh
i'm excited about this one should i be
worried about bear stearns in terms of
liquidity and get my money out there no
no no bear stearns is fine do not take
your money out this is real if there's
one takeaway other than a plus 400
somewhere bear stearns is not in trouble
i mean if anything they're more likely
to be taken over
don't move your money from fair that's
just being silly don't be silly don't be
silly
oh no here we go bear stearns shares
down 90 this morning and it's not just
bear pretty much every single bank
don't take your money out of air if
anything they're going to be taken over
oh gosh jim cramer that's rough i think
so
bear stearns they were taken over by jp
morgan at 10 and i think they were at
around 100
before things really hit the fan so
pretty bad call
yeah jim cramer this this was a rough
one uh and i think he tried to paper
over it later but there's no the clip
the proof is in the clip and then
there's the the second clip which is
kind of like a follow-up to that so we
saw the bear stearns clip kind of lesson
from that learning from jim cramer you
want to sell low right um right once
things have
hit their bottom that's when you sell
out this is the second half of that you
know that's only half the statement and
this was after the 2008 financial crisis
so for investors what is your advice
today okay whatever money you may need
for the next five years please take it
out of the stock market right now this
week i do not believe that you should
risk those assets in the stock market
even if you would take a tremendous loss
and selling your stocks at this decline
you say take it out i don't care i do
not care where stocks are i do not care
where stocks have been i care where
they're going but if you need it uh
after five years then don't touch it
well yes she kind of she tossed him a
bit of a life jacket with that you know
what about after five years he's like oh
yeah it's like you know i kind of in
finance uh kind of a rule of thumb is if
you're if you need the money in the next
five years not to put in the stock
market like let's say it's a down
payment i think she was kind of like
throwing him a life jack to be like oh
but what about after five years but
selling everything you need for the next
five at the bottom sell it all at the
bottom buy high and sell low right
that's nice that's how you make money
right jim cramer he has a bad reputation
i don't want to be too harsh on him
compared to like the aig and stuff i'm
gonna give him
six or seven uh i think it's a little
alarmist and and obviously that's not
good financial advice that's kind of how
everyone was feeling at that time so i i
don't wanna no mercy dude this guy has
deep finance backgrounds i'm giving him
a 10 out of 10 bad calls
all right so far we've seen a lot of bad
calls
a lot of age-like milk moments but this
next one hasn't aged like milk yet we're
going to find out this is a present call
this is very recent let's see what you
think about this one richard i want to
hear your take all right of course
worries of relationships between el
salvador and the imf does any of that
matter to some of the investors that
you're talking to
no
i don't think
a lot of these organizations like the
imf or world bank are really relevant in
the world based on on bitcoin they're
only relevant because they can print
money they can make the sdr you know
they can make money out of thin air you
can't do that on a bitcoin standard
oops i'm going to have to go ahead and
call a foul on that one
that's a red card i think i just i just
want to point out to everyone if you
missed it he's wearing a tether shirt
while saying at the same time oh the imf
can just print money that they're
irrelevant they're relevant to bitcoin
they can just print money you can't do
that in the bitcoin standard um
yeah well maybe maybe maybe not uh we'll
find out i mean i think time will
quickly tell on the tether debacle but
either way i'm i'm going to go ahead and
call that a
seven or an eight because i don't really
know if it's a bad call i'm gonna
preemptively call it a bad call but
we'll find out all right yeah that's
fair i think that's fair and i i do love
the uh you know saying the imf is
irrelevant you know one of the largest
financial bodies in the world and
irrelevant dude i'll give it a seven so
far you know it is it is preemptive it
is preemptive but uh i've seen i've seen
the coffeezilla videos i i know i know
what's up so uh
all right we'll see fair enough richard
while you have gone through the gauntlet
looking at these with me thank you for
rating them with me now i have someone
credible actually doing it and of course
my of course genius calls as well and
that's basically it i hope you guys at
home learned something go follow richard
coffin at the plain bagel for some
common sense investing education and
with that being said ladies and
gentlemen that's it i'll see you guys in
the next